ok bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi
sia un gameplay anzi l'ex play su un
videogioco che si chiama mac pixel
quindi ragazzi iniziamo questa nuova
serie su mac pixar
voi non avete idea ok non avete voi non
ce l'avete l'idea sms presenza io presto
to start bene bellissima la partenza da
dio story mode figli sia questo erano
ciak story mode
ah ok devo stuprare un vecchio per
entrare nello story mode va bene charter
one chapter ii facciamo il primo lui
sarebbe mcpeak se comunque che sembra
più una donna che un uomo è però a devo
buttarla nel nel buco ma no
ma qual è il senso ma per quale motivo
non abbiamo ancora neanche iniziato e
già non sto capendo un cazzo bellissimo
primo livello è questo il primo ok
facciamo le cose in ordine chapter one
round one epic saved dei allora prima in
tre ragazzi lo scopo di questo videogame
e salvare la giornata mac wicksell devo
salvare la giornata del che devo fare
devono accogliere questo uno ad hoc
tieni tuo regalo
sto prendendo a calci tizio quindi non
funziona devo ammettere che c'è solo dog
è una ma che cazzo fa ma è scemo eh va
bene lo sull isola senza un motivo me
pixel non ho salvato la giornata 2 siamo
in una scuola ma i pixel da buongiorno è
la madonna che tette cosa devo fare devo
salvare la giornata salvo e buonuomo
quello ci aveva una dinamite nel culo e
mostrato a tutto in aria di giusto era
giusto dovuto care tizio che questo ce
l'ho fatta perfetto tempio allora quindi
ragazzi l'obiettivo è quello di fare
cose salvando il livello il problema è
che ho dato fuoco a un monaco si sa
perché esplode tutto senza un cazzo di
motivo però adesso riuscito a farne solo
uno per adesso un vulcano inserisci la
vergine ma cos'è sta roba
mi spiegate il se questo è un osso ok e
cosa me ne fa ad infilarlo nel culo
della vacca bene adesso non è vergine
sono convinto
niente esploso tutto ragazzi non ha
senso non capisco
sono su un treno va bene su un treno ce
la faccio ragazzi sono riuscito a farne
solo uno non sa che la nonna è cosa devo
fare devo salvare la giornata che state
lo faccia una bomba qui non toccare la
bomba sarà sicuramente sbagliato prendi
la dentiera da lui dagli la dentiera
brutto stronzo che cosa vuoi ti sta
mangiando il piede la dentiera l'ho
fatta
ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta ci credo
era giusto perché ho dovuto dare la
dentiera al tizio che ha calciato fuori
la bomba non ha senso ragazzi avete
intuito questo uk
ma che cosa ci sono i personaggi di
happiness la faccio l'allarme l'allarme
tutti in classe bambini che ci fa vj che
insegna niente esploso tutto ci
mancherebbe infatti 2 su 6 che non è
male pensavo peggio ritorniamo al primo
che sono fare qua mettere la maione ma
perché niente non ho capito cosa devo
fare giustizia e stranissimi o devo
prendere la la dinamica là sopra a di
stronzo ma no va da sé niente rega non
riesco a farne uno non ho capito il
senso vulcano cosa faccio nel vulcano il
vulcano è difficile inserisci la vergine
dove cazzo sta la vela è lei la vergine
saver ginesi a non era vergine perfetto
ma che cosa ne so io si sa di cosa parla
anche nell'isola ma dio mio ha chiesto
tizio c'è una c'è un ragno una cosa è un
alieno che si fuma una canna e tanto
esplode tutto uguale bene a devo dare lo
dog all'alieno tipo ce la posso fare
prima o poi chara parola fastidi rally
miki impossibile a candela la candela a
lui si è fatta è giusto è giusto ce l'ho
fatta ragazzi ci credono inserisci la
vergine chi è allora non sei tu non sono
né lei io sono io mi butto a si posso
buttarmi non ci vuoi far affanculo dyer
r
ero io il verde la ver ma che è un
maschio e una femmina su cui non si
capisce un cazzo da ben maschio credo
sia un maschio tiro di calcio ai bambini
e salvo la scuola non lo so cosa devo
fare lega cioè un armadietto che sia
questo si apriva c'è una bomba e cosa
vuoi che ci faccia questa bomba vabbè ma
prendi la parola e cosa ma perché ha tra
l'altro mi sa che se ne azzecchi tre di
fila vinci un bonus cosa che non ce la
farò mai nella vita però ma prova da lì
lo do gas ragazzo di alieno quello dog
zio a perché era perché era lo dog la
bomba amiche non ho neanche capito
geniale lega manca solo la scuola perché
dovevano un trofeo
ok c'è pensavo fosse messo male sto
gioco ma non così male sono riuscito a
vincere i primi sei livelli ragazzi è
stato un parto con play facciamo i
secondi la facciamo questi salve mi
spaventa è la cosa cosa devo fare
quincho seriamente paura di vedere sti
livelli parte dei top cos'è un party
salve perché c'è caparezza che sta
ballando vi posso darti una mia lazio
nola dall dj lodo di lei che non sembra
però martin garriques però la metto sul
piatto è giusto per un attimo su sperato
lega però la vedo
sognare non è mai proibito sono in un
vicolo c'è un barbone ciao cosa deve
darti in questa cosa tieni ta regalo
anzi la metto nel cestino caso è quello
che succede questo e successo spiegato e
non ho capito niente ma perché deve
sempre esplodere qualcosa di sto gioco
non ho capito riuscirò per la prima è la
madonna calciare il tizio in acqua
prendere lo stereo e darlo al tizio
fatto male zio
oddio corto circuito non ce la faccio
scommessa o regalo impossibile
non ho capito se salve a questa è la
bomba perfetto e posso darti niente
neanche a provarci santo iddio ora in
questo non son riuscito a farne neanche
uno il primo tentativo ma che palle
una nucleare un serpente una porta che
si deve aprire credo di spread apro la
porta però il portellone perfetto e no
niente organi c'è verso mai nella vita o
impossibile se i tagli o trovare una
bomba e per caso qua dentro
eccola l'ho trovata subito perfetto ma
mi fai fare qualcosa ma è zio vai a
schiacciare file dj fammi capire aveva
la bomba nei capelli
aveva la bomba di cappello ma che cazzo
ne so io per risolvere la situazione il
suo gioco devi fare le cose che non ti
aspetteresti mai tipo aprire il cestino
perché c'è una tartaruga ninja con la
bomba in testa che è tra l'altro mi ha
anche fatto esplodere quindi niente non
era neanche quello d'api ecco la piscina
è impossibile non l'ho capito a meno che
non mi devo aiutare io come prima e
giusto era giusto dovevo scappare ma è
ovvio ma non c'ha privare era la mia
seconda scelta e per carità di dio c'è
un marcio in coso qua lo metto nella
macchinetta erano erano dei soldi va
bene bene ho salvato la giornata nel
modo migliore possibile fantastic
offrendo la bomba la calcio nel serpente
assolutamente sì non faceva una piega
guarda parka [ __ ] dai e la moneta
metti la moneta nel cestino giusto
certo dovevo far sì che il barbone si
lanciasse nel cestino per tappare la
bomba non avevo proprio dubbi gradini
che si può fare quindi mezzo nella
valigetta e l'unica roba che mi rimane
da fare se non dai l'incrocio posso fare
caso due cose insieme
chest eschimese
non è vero e proprio la palano ha
prodotto una palata alla bomba dona
tutto
vabbè lasciamo perdere questo perché
faccia in sta minchia di green c'è una
bomba l'ha dentro questo qua si denuda e
cioè ma secondo te io vedevo la palla di
neve solo perché hai messo dei dei
cosini grigi o la prendo qua o là lancio
su www sulla dinamite direttamente a ok
non potevo fare così per tutti i livelli
a cosa mica sto giocando ragazzi quanto
e nonsense sta roba spiegatemi la corda
ragazzo li facciamo l'ultimo del primo
capitolo che sarebbe questo che ancora
non ho capito lo stesso giorno io stavo
facendo la fila ma passo avanti che sono
più bello salve cos'è successo
esploso tutto di caffè va bene senza
ombra di dubbio sensore abbiamo un
estintore
mi scusi non volevo bene ovviamente non
fa una piega
devo guardare fuori
non devo guardare forno esploso niente
raga non c'è verso un giorno c'è un
ragno che già mista in cui issimo io non
ho parole reja che cosa cazzo sta
giocando
ma cos'è una trincea signorsì signore
come ti chiami in faccia di merda
io ho preso l'elmetto servirà qualcosa
sicuro
mettilo sulla bomba adesso do io gli
ordini adesso dai calci alla bomba ed
esploso tutto va bene come non detto sei
su sei sbagliati ragazzi sono un [ __ ]
genio no vabbè è impossibile ve lo dico
è veramente impossibile caffè devo
prendere un secchio metto il secchio al
posto della macchinetta del caffè e la
madonna che cazzo fa ma questo è tutto
scemo bene complimenti
vabbè ascensore lega piazzetta sia caso
non lo so quindi niente ci siamo
schiacciati uguale niente raga non ce la
faccio impossibile questo è aperto tra
l'altro c'è una tanica di gas nascosta
spiegami perché offre con l'elemento ci
devo fare sicuramente qualcosa lega
perché non rido in testa anno me lo
metto io in testa gli dico di fare le
flessioni lo schiaffeggia gli dico di
andare sulla bomba e di eva non potevi
farlo tu deficiente raga non mi faccio
domande tutto strano suo gioco non è un
problema ragazzi che si può fare in sto
minchia di livello al secchio serve lo
do a lui mi ha schiaffeggiato era giusto
ragazzi siamo a due di fila secco anche
questo siamo a tre di fila potrebbe
essere epico aprì e buttano su su cosa
su cosa non fuori
[ __ ] no si era giusto tre su tre
cos'è sta roba bonus round cos'è un
livello bonus perché non fatti tre di
fila ci sono dei gattini aiuto che cazzo
stai facendo
no no non ho capito il senso però è
esplosa la mucca va bene ma voi ragazzi
mancano due la bomba nel coso
dell'occhiello no
prima o poi lo zucchero e rega questo
non l'ho capito ora il bagno regala
servirà qualcosa lo metto dentro
grandissimo zio il ragno ha salvato la
situazione.complimenti molto la bomba
fuori e poi chiudo subito parte che se
succedesse mai una roba del genere.ed è
infatti come come ma come allora
l'importante era buttar fuori la bomba
poi non importa se moriamo annegati
l'importante la butta fuori da bomba poi
chissenefrega
ma va ragazzi ho completato il capitolo
1 e questo è già qualcosa capitolo ii
sia appena sbloccato perfetto non voglio
vedere di che si tratta perché ciò paura
però sarà una figata quello so convinto
ma voi ragazzi concludo con il primo
episodio di mac pixel eccessivamente
nonsense prove spero che ha vinto vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi cosa sento se vi è
piaciuto affatto un commento è un mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook
coniglio totale estinzione se il city 16
mettiamolo prossimo vico e ragazzi